-Our next guest is a talented
musician and actress
you know from shows
such as "Lizzie McGuire"
and "Younger."
She both produces --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
"Brideshead Revisited"
didn't do as hot.
[ Laughter ]
She both produces and stars
in "How I Met Your Father,"
which is available on Hulu,
with new episodes
releasing on Tuesday.
Let's take a look.
-Oh, I'm so happy you're home!
I missed you so much.
-We don't have time for
"I miss yous"!
Dish.
How was your date with Ian?
Was he tall?
-Yes.
-Was he a good listener?
-Were his eyes
as kind as his photo?
-Yes!
-Whoooo!
Why aren't you jumping?
-Because he's moving
to Australia.
Yeah.
-Soph, I am so sorry.
Did you bang one out anyway?
-Please welcome back to the show
Hilary Duff!
Hello, Hilary!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, Seth Meyers.
How are you?
-It's so lovely to see you.
-Oh, my gosh, thank you so much.
So happy
to be on the show again.
What took you four years
to invite me back, huh?
-I know.
It's really odd.
I'm gonna take it up
with the talent department.
I'm pretty upset.
[ Laughter ]
You haven't --
Let me just say this.
It's been four years.
You haven't aged a day.
You look fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I had a lot of hair and makeup
to help with that,
but I definitely have.
-Well, one thing,
in the four years since
I've last seen you, you have
added two more children.
Congratulations on that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah.
Sometimes I ask myself why, but
for the most part, it's good.
You just added one, too, right?
-Yeah.
So, we've got a 4-month-old,
and I think that is
the conversation my wife and I
have every day, which is we love
her, but we're also, "Why?"
-Yeah, you can't not love them.
Like, they're insanely cute
and lovable but, you know,
you're like,
"Wait.
We had a good thing going here.
What were we thinking?"
[ Laughs ]
-So how --
Your oldest now is 9?
Is that right?
-He is, he is.
-How is he with having
two babies around?
-He'll be 10 in March.
-...or two little ones around?
-How is with it?
-Yeah.
-He's, honestly, the best.
-That's great.
-He loves babies,
he loves little kids.
He's so good with the girls.
But he's my child that's just,
like, all good inside.
And my middle daughter, like,
probably the house is
gonna burn down at some point.
Like, she's just a wild one.
But we love her,
and it's so much fun.
It's just, you know --
The no sleep?
I heard you don't get
your sleep back
until your youngest child is 6.
You start recouping sleep,
and that sounds,
like, really faraway away.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I had my kids later in
life, so I think, in six years,
I won't be regaining sleep,
I'll just be starting to die.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, maybe that's --
maybe that's
what's gonna happen to you.
-So I heard --
You know, I'm very fascinated
by the skills people picked up
during the pandemic.
Guitar?
Is this true?
-It's totally true
that I started taking
Zoom online guitar lessons.
Shout-out to Teague.
What's up?
Miss you, buddy.
My husband had bought me
a guitar for my birthday --
my 30th birthday --
and I didn't pick it up
for three years.
And then I started playing,
and I can't remember anything,
but if I took a class, I think
it would still be in there.
So, we started with funny, like,
theme songs to old movies
and TV shows, so I can play,
like, "Batman"
and "Mission: Impossible"
and very easy,
simple, simple things.
And I learned
the White Stripes song.
[ Imitating
"Seven Nation Army" ]
-Oh, yeah, the "Nation Army."
Something?
-"Seven Nation Army."
-How many nations?
One of them.
A number of nations.
-But please don't ask me
to do it for you,
because I will fail miserably
right now.
-Well, this is very exciting.
There's a stranger
in your house,
and he's about
to hand you a guitar.
[ Laughter ]
I heard --
This is very exciting.
You made an appearance
on a very popular show
that is dear to you,
"The Bachelor."
-Yeah. Yeah,
it is very dear to my heart.
It's not yours?
-How did it come about
that you got to appear
on "The Bachelor"?
-Um, you know what?
I think it was just promo
for the show.
It was, like, tossed out there
with the promo packet,
if you will, of, like, options.
And my publicist was like,
"I'm sure you're not gonna
be so into this."
And I was like, "What?!
Why would you think that?
Like, you don't know me
at all?!"
Like, I actually love
"The Bachelor,"
and I haven't watched
in about a year,
but we can blame
my youngest child for that.
But, yeah, I've been fascinated
by "The Bachelor"
for a really long time.
So getting to go
and be on set and have them,
like, take my phone away
from me, I felt really cool.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's just top --
everything's top-secret.
There's maybe 75 producers,
like, running around with, like,
ear things in and --
But everything's
just unfolding naturally.
Like, I don't know.
I thought there was gonna be,
like, a script and a this.
It's not really like that.
It is a, like,
social experiment.
Maybe we're all in a simulation.
I don't know.
It was fascinating.
[ Laughter ]
-I only watched one season,
and I got in way too deep.
[ Laughter ]
I was way
too emotionally invested,
and I realized,
"I don't think I'm prepared
to take this journey again."
[ Laughter ]
-Was it "The Bachelor"
or "The Bachelorette"
that you watched?
-I think I watched a
"Bachelorette" season.
And I think --
-Both equally as satisfying,
so you can't really go wrong.
It's just, can you get in,
and can you stay there?
-"Satisfying"
isn't a word I'd use.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, okay, okay.
-Like, I found --
Like, the way --
I feel like -- I don't know.
I feel like,
I've never done crack,
but I feel like if I did,
I wouldn't say like,
"That was very satisfying."
[ Laughter ]
It's, like, addictive.
-I'm with you there.
I'm with you there.
I maybe used the wrong word.
I also have not used crack.
-Yeah.
-But sometimes watching
"The Bachelor"
does feel that way.
-Well, it seems like we have
our resolutions for next year.
[ Laughter ]
So, "How I Met Your Father."
This is not --
I think a lot of people
might assume from the title
this is a reboot of
"How I Met Your Mother,"
but is it safe to say
it's a sequel of sorts?
-I think so.
I think that's kind of
how we're presenting it,
because it's
a completely original cast,
and, you know, we're not, like,
picking up where they left off.
We're not -- you know,
my character isn't Ted Mosby.
Like, we are new people
going on our new life adventure,
figuring out things at 30.
But it ends the episode
in a really cool way
that I think people will
understand our take on the show.
And you know, obviously,
borrowing --
it's such a great concept
to be telling your kid
the story of how you met
their parent,
and now it's being told
from the female perspective.
And, yeah, we play with
a lot of, like, flashbacks
and flash-forwards,
which tells a story, like,
very quickly
and brings a great energy.
But it really is its own show,
and, you know,
it's about 30-year-olds
doing life at 30
and what that looks like now
in the age of online dating
and limitless options and being,
like, swipeable.
It's just completely stressful.
-[ Laughs ]
-But, also, you know,
it's a love story
between a group of friends
that are kind of
a pack of weirdos that all
love and accept each other
and are just...
you know,
trying to figure out their 30s
and what they want out of life.
-You have a very cool
narrator in the show.
That was obviously a big part
of "How I Met Your Mother,"
as well, and it's Kim Cattrall,
who is one of the coolest people
in the world.
Did you actually
get to hang out with her
since she was sort of
a narrator role?
-Yeah, I spent
a little bit of time with her,
and she's --
she's a beast, man.
She shot like 10 episodes
in one day.
Like, all of her stuff
was really fast,
but she just showed up
and kind of schooled us all.
It was like, "Oh, damn.
That's how you do it," you know?
She's such an icon.
And I wasn't supposed
to be at work, and I'm like,
"Oh, come hell or high water,
I'm showing up."
Like, "Out of my way.
Where's Kim?"
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, it's really cool
to have her play the future
Sophie and tell that story.
She's really witty,
but she's, like, warm and open.
And there's something comforting
about having her tell the story
and actually seeing her,
because, I don't know about you,
but it would be so nice
to see the future me
and know that I turned out okay.
I made some good choices
that got me to the right places
in life at that point.
So there's that, like, comfort
in that part of the show,
which she's obviously
a big part of.
So, also, the show takes place
in New York,
and when I think of Kim,
I think of New York City.
-Yes.
-So it's a cool element.
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
I do hope, next time,
we can get you back in the city.
-Um, well, I really hope that
next time you actually invite me
to go day-drinking with you.
That's what I really want.
-All right,
but here's the thing.
Wait a second.
-I also haven't gotten
that invitation.
-All right, Hilary, but I think
a lot of people
want to do day-drinking.
They think,
"Oh, it's fake or phony,
and you do shots of water."
This is a real thing.
-I don't think
you know me very well, Seth.
Let's go.
[ Laughter ]
It's on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hilary Duff, everybody.
New episodes of
"How I Met Your Father"
are available Tuesdays on Hulu.
We'll be right back.